[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir
und zusammen mit meiner Kollegin Antonia
Heyer erzählen wir euch jeden Tag von
Kriminalfällen die manchmal schon
Jahrhunderte zurückliegen und manchmal
auch aus unserer jüngsten Vergangenheit
stammen 1 ist ihnen allen gemein sie
beschäftigen uns und andere Menschen
noch immer lassen uns nicht los
schockieren uns und haben eine Bedeutung
die weit über den konkreten Fall
hinausgeht alle Antonia hi zusammen ja
das ist richtig dieser Fall ist ein
gutes bzw schreckliches Beispiel bei mir
hat er sich eingebrannt besser gesagt
dass gruselige Fahndungsbild als Kind
habe ich das immer im Fernsehen gesehen
und hatte pure Angst bis heute habe ich
das noch ganz präsent vor Augen es geht
um den Masken Mann
dies ist der zweite Teil unserer
Geschichte über einen Sexualverbrecher
der zwischen 1992 und 2011 mindestens 40
Jungen im Alter von 8 bis 13
missbrauchte und mindestens drei von
ihnen tötete
wenn ihr Teil 1 nicht gehört habt dann
holt das am besten jetzt gleich noch mal
nach bevor mit dieser Folge weiter macht
aber Mirko vielleicht kannst du uns
trotzdem ein kurzes was bisher geschah
geben na klar im März 1992 beginnt in
Niedersachsen eine Serie von
Missbrauchstaten an Jungs der Täter ist
stets in Schwarz gekleidet trägt
Handschuhe und eine schwarze Maske eine
Sturmhaube was ihm bald den Namen der
Maskenmann einbringt immer wieder trinkt
er in Kinderheime Schullandheime und
Zeltlager ein und schleicht sich in die
Schlafräume oder zählte der Kinder mit
der Zeit werden die Taten immer dreister
ab 1994 bricht er auch in
Einfamilienhäuser ein und missbraucht
Jungs in ihrem eigenen Zimmer oft nur
eine Tür von den Eltern entfernt
manchmal schläft ein Geschwisterkind
neben dem Opfer
bei vielen dieser Taten wird der beinahe
erwischt kann aber in letzter Sekunde
fliehen einige Male stößt er auf
Gegenwehr und ergreift dann ebenfalls
die Flucht und gleich am Anfang dieser
unheimlichen Serie begeht er einen
ersten Mord
am 31 März 1992 verschwindet der
13-Jährige Stefan aus einem Internat in
Scheeßel in Niedersachsen
5 Wochen später findet man seine
gefesselte Leiche vergraben in den
pferdener Dünen einem Naturschutzgebiet
im Stadtwald von Verden ebenfalls in
Niedersachsen
die Ermittlungen laufen ins Leere drei
Jahre später der zweite Mord am Morgen
des 24 Juli 1995 wird in einem Zeltlager
in Schleswig-Holstein der achtjährige
Dennis vermisst seine Leiche finden
Touristen zwei Wochen später vergraben
in einer Düne in Dänemark
und da sind wir jetzt im Jahr 1995 nach
zwei Morgen und dutzenden
Missbrauchstaten
in den Folgejahren wird es etwas stiller
um den Masken an offensichtlich ist er
vorsichtig geworden finde ich ziemlich
erstaunlich da bisher so dreist
vorgegangen ist doch mindestens zweimal
in den Jahren 1998 und 99 dringt der
erneut in schullandheimer ein und
missbraucht Jungen oder versucht es es
ist auch zumindest aus heutiger Sicht
unglaublich dass nach allem was
geschehen ist die ganze Sache nicht mit
großem Aufwand und aller Kraft verfolgt
wird
die Fälle liegen bei unterschiedlichen
Polizeidirektionen der große
Zusammenhang fehlt noch immer halten
viele die Geschichten von einem großen
ganz in schwarz gekleideten und mit
einer Maske bewährten Mann der nachts in
Kinderzimmer und Schlafräume kommt für
kindliche Hirngespinste für
Gruselgeschichten wie sie sich Jungs nun
einmal erzählen wenn sie einander auf
Klassenfahrt Angst einjagen wollen und
in Bremen wo mindestens sieben Jungs in
ihren eigenen Kinderzimmern im
Einfamilienhaus der Eltern vom
Maskenmann missbraucht wurden weigert
sich die Polizei eine Warnung
auszusprechen um die Öffentlichkeit
nicht übergebühr zu beunruhigen das
alles ändert sich 2001 am Morgen des 5
September bemerkt eine Lehrerin in einem
Schullandheim in Wulsbüttel dass ein
Neunjähriger Schüler fehlt er heißt
Dennis genau wie das zweite Mordopfer
des Täters
sofort setzt eine großangelegte Suche
ein
Hundertschaften der Polizei unterstützt
von Soldaten und Jägern durch kämmen die
Umgebung ohne Erfolg zwei Wochen später
dann die traurige Gewissheit der kleine
Dennis wurde ermordet ein Pilzsammler
findet die Leiche in einem Waldstück bei
Hettstedt etwa 40 Autominuten von
Wulsbüttel entfernt
die Polizei gründet die Soko Dennis
anfangs sind es 40 Beamte die nach dem
Mörder suchen sie gehen tausenden
Hinweisen nach Ziehen Verbindungen zu
den ersten beiden Morgen und den
Missbrauchsfällen immer neue Opfer und
Zeugen melden sich und der Fall versetzt
die ganze Regionen Aufruhr Kinder haben
Angst Eltern sorgen sich um ihre
Sicherheit schullandfahrten werden
storniert trotz aller Bemühungen dauert
es noch zehn Jahre bis zum
entscheidenden Hinweis
1995 war ein Zehnjähriger in seinem
Kinderzimmer missbraucht worden seine
Schwester die im selben Zimmer schlief
war dabei ebenfalls wach geworden hatte
geschrien und den Täter so verjagt wir
haben seine Geschichte in der letzten
Folge erzählt
der Junge 2001 ist er bereits fast ein
junger Mann erinnert sich plötzlich
daran dass ihn kurz vor der Tat ein
Betreuer auf einer Jugendfreizeit
ausführlich über das Haus seiner Eltern
ausgefragt hat er wollte ganz genau
wissen wo welches Zimmer ist und was wo
steht und er ist sich zu 80% sicher sich
an den Namen des Betreuers zu erinnern
Martin
am 14 April 2011 verhaftet die Polizei
in Hamburg den 40-Jährigen
Sozialpädagogen Martin nei den Mann
hinter der Maske schon in den ersten
Vernehmungen gesteht er die
Missbrauchstaten und die drei Morde aber
Mirko wer ist Martina
so lange unentdeckt bleiben
martinal wird im Dezember 1970 geboren
er ist kein besonders guter Schüler
schafft aber schließlich das Abitur und
studiert Mathematik Physik und Pädagogik
ein bizarres Detail
1996 noch während seines Studiums zu
einem Zeitpunkt an dem er bereits zwei
Kinder getötet hat wird im Lehramt
Studenten ein zwölfjähriges Pflegekind
anvertraut das insgesamt vier Jahre bei
Martin Neil lebt das ist so unglaublich
das kann doch nicht wahr sein sie ist so
etwas möglich aber klar niemand ahnte
damals mit wem man es zu tun hat nein
ist ein unauffälliger junger Mann er
studiert Pädagogik engagiert sich beim
Bremer Amt für Soziale Dienste und
natürlich ist er ziemlich jung und
bezieht zu dieser Zeit Bafög aber der
Bedarf an Pflegeeltern ist groß und man
muss auch sagen dass es in dieser
Beziehung keine Hinweise auf Missbrauch
gibt
das passt sehr gut zum Vorgehen von nein
der zwar immer wieder mit Kindern
arbeitet aber in seiner Tätigkeit nie
übergriffig wird die Ausbildung zum
Lehrer bricht nei im Referendariat ab
und arbeitet fortan bei verschiedenen
sozialpädagogischen Projekten Kollegen
und Verwandte haben keine Ahnung von
seinem Doppelleben wie so oft ist es ein
unauffälliger Mensch von dessen Taten
hinterher alle schockiert sind und doch
geriet er schon vor 2011 in den Fokus
der Polizei
schon 1987 im Alter von 17 Jahren
erpresste er zwei Elternpaare in Bremen
und drohte ihnen mit der Entführung und
Ermordung ihrer Kinder wenn sie nicht
150.000 Marktzeiten
1989 wurde er dafür nach dem
Jugendstrafrecht zu gemeinnütziger
Arbeit verurteilt mit Vollendung des 24
lebensjahres wurde diese Strafe jedoch
aus dem Register gelöscht nur dadurch
war es beispielsweise möglich dass er
als Pflegevater akzeptiert wurde
2005 hat er das erste Mal wegen eines
Sexualdeliktes mit Polizei und Justiz zu
tun ihm wird sexueller Missbrauch in
zwei minder schweren Fällen vorgeworfen
das Verfahren wird gegen eine Zahlung
von 1800 Euro eingestellt
2006 erpresst der ein Sozialarbeiter aus
Berlin und droht in wegen Besitzes von
Kinderpornografie anzuzeigen 20.000 Euro
will er haben und landet erneut wegen
Erpressung vor Gericht er wird zu einer
Freiheitsstrafe von zehn Monaten auf
Bewährung verurteilt im Zuge der
Ermittlungen dazu findet die Polizei
aber auch etwa 30.000 pornografische
Aufnahmen von Kindern auf seinem
Computer es lässt sich leider nicht
feststellen wann die Bilder gespeichert
wurden und wann zuletzt auf sie
zugegriffen wurde deswegen wird das
Verfahren wegen vermuteter Verjährung
eingestellt
niemandem fällt auf dass einige der
Kinder auf den Fotos zu den Opfern des
berüchtigten maskenmannes gehören
2007 gerät er sogar ins Visier der
sokodennis er passt in das Täterprofil
das inzwischen erstellt wurde mai
streitet aber alles ab ein Tatverdacht
lässt sich nicht der Härten
im Herbst 2011 steht Martin nei in Stade
vor Gericht und liegt erneut ein
umfassendes Geständnis ab er habe die
Kinder aus Furcht vor Entdeckung getötet
sagt er mit dem kleinen Dennis den er
1995 aus einem Zeltlager entführte habe
er mehrere Tage in einem Ferienhäuschen
verbracht am Ende habe er ihn töten
müssen denn er habe ihn ja nicht
entkommen lassen können
schließlich wird knife für drei Morde
und 40 sexuelle Übergriffe auf
Minderjährige zu 20 Jahren Haft mit
anschließender Sicherheitsverwahrung bis
ans Lebensende verurteilt diese
Sicherheitsverwahrung wird später vom
Bundesgerichtshof aufgehoben nach
verbüßen der Haftstrafe muss ein neues
Gutachten klären ob er noch immer eine
Gefahr für die Allgemeinheit ist
dass ein solcher Prozess für die Opfer
seiner Missbrauchstaten und die
Angehörigen der Ermordeten Kinder
bedeutet das kann man sich wohl kaum
vorstellen und sicher ist es für jeden
anders einerseits wird alles wieder
aufgewühlt und neue schreckliche kaum zu
ertragende Details kommen ans Licht
andererseits finden einige vielleicht
auch ein Stück weit Frieden nun da der
Täter erkannt gefasst und verurteilt ist
obwohl ich mir das wiederum auch nur
schwer vorstellen kann sexueller
Missbrauch ist Mord an der Seele in
diesem Fall Kinderseelen und ob es sowas
wie Frieden jemals geben wird das
bezweifle ich
wie vielen Kindern Martin mal wirklich
Leid zugefügt hat wird sich wohl nie
ganz klären lassen wie viele seine Opfer
haben aus Scham geschwiegen oder aus
Angst oft drohte der Mann mit der Maske
den Kindern sie oder ihre Eltern zu
töten wenn sie etwas erzählten das
Grauen das ein solcher nächtlicher
Übergriff in einem acht neun
zehnjährigen ausgelöst haben muss das
kann man sich nicht ausmalen vermutlich
werden wir auch nie Gewissheit haben wie
viele Morde auf Martin nice Konto gehen
im Jahr 2004 ist der zehnjährige
Jonathan auf Klassenfahrt in einem
Sommerlager im Nordwesten der
französischen Atlantikküste er teilt
sich ein Zimmer mit fünf Freunden die
Tür dieses Zimmers hat keinen Griff an
der Innenseite deshalb die Türen die
richtig geschlossen wird das ist eine
Sicherheitsmaßnahme damit die Kinder
nicht in der Falle sitzen sollte es mal
brennen aber es ist auch eine einfache
Möglichkeit einzudringen
am Morgen des 7 April ist Jonathan
verschwunden jede Suche bleibt erfolglos
zwei Wochen später kontaktieren
Ermittler des Bundeskriminalamts die
französische Polizei der Fall scheint
Ähnlichkeiten mit den Morgen des
maskenmanns aufzuweisen nachdem zu
dieser Zeit noch immer gesucht wird
zeugen wollen zudem in der Nacht des
Verschwindens ein Auto mit deutschem
Kennzeichen in der Nähe des Sommerlagers
gesehen haben
Ende Mai wird die Leiche des Jungen
gefunden gefesselt mit einem Betonblock
beschwert in einem kleinen Teich
versenkt auf dem Gelände eines
ehemaligen Klosters in der Region als
Martina 2011 vor Gericht steht und
freimütig drei Morde steht bestreitet
der aber Jonathan ermordet zu haben eine
Kreditkartenabrechnung verschafft ihm
ein Alibi und der Verdacht lässt sich
wieder nicht erhalten doch sieben Jahre
später meldet sich ein mit Häftling und
behauptet nein habe ihm gegenüber die
Entführung und Ermordung des jungen
zugegeben im Januar 2021 wird er nach
Frankreich überstellt nachdem dort
Anklage gegen ihn erhoben wurde doch die
Tat kann ihm nicht nachgewiesen werden
fünf Monate später sitzt Martini wieder
in seiner Zelle in Deutschland
die Geschichte des maskenmannes hat noch
einen traurigen Schlusspunkt erinnert
ihr euch noch an den Vater von Stefan
das ist der Vater des ersten Mordopfers
Stefans Vater hat selbst unermüdlich
versucht den Mörder seines Sohnes zu
fangen und hat Jahre seines Lebens und
ein Vermögen in diese Suche investiert
der sagte damit ich eines Tages in
Frieden sterben kann muss ich wissen wer
das getan hat und neun Tage nach Prozess
Ende starb er auf einem Fahrradausflug
an einem Herzinfarkt vielleicht war er
auf gewisse Weise das letzte Opfer des
Masken Mannes
[Musik]
die Geschichte von Martin Neid dem
Masken Mann haben wir erzählt anhand von
Artikeln und Berichten der
Lokalredaktionen Budden und binnen von
Radio Bremen der Kreiszeitung Stade der
Süddeutschen Zeitung des Spiegels der
Rotenburger Rundschau sowie der deutsch-
und englischsprachigen Wikipedia sehr
informativ und bewegend war eine Ausgabe
von stern TV aus dem Jahr 2021 über den
Fall in der auch Opfer Angehörige und
Ermittler zu Wort kommen wir danken Euch
sehr dass ihr dabei wart und hoffen dass
ihr wieder einschaltet hier bei Tatort
Deutschland dem täglichen True Crime
Podcast von Bild bis dann eure Toni und
euer Mikro
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband
Postproduktion durch die wake-studios